so this illustration is
insight into end of life caregiving
i wanted to create awareness on this
topic also in a sense like reach out to
my audience who can relate emotionally
with my drawing people who have been
through end-of-life caribbean or see
caregiving or seeing people their loved
ones
you know battling with terminal illness
but essentially i just wanted
people to who can relate with it to feel
acknowledged in a way of their feelings
like okay i've been through that
situation i've had similar feelings that
helplessness that loneliness
in my practice i try to
explore the idea of how illustration can
bear witness to grief
and
aid in the healing process
because i see how it can
touch people's lives beautify places
yeah i think those who
have personally experienced it might
be able to understand this feeling
of sitting by the bedside
and watching your loved one fade away
and i feel like maybe now if people
don't understand it i feel maybe one at
one some point in their life they might
come to understand it because death is
something that
all of us will face sometime in our life
it feels like i put my heart out here on
the table for everyone to see
feels very raw and vulnerable
[Music]